vous n'aviez pas de travail en Grèce oui
mais il y en a travail pas beaucoup le
pays pas beaucoup d'argent oui et ici ça
vous suffit ce que vous gagnez
Ahou c'est pas beaucoup mais un petit
peu
[Musique]
pleuse
à l'usine sur le chantier un ouvrier sur
TR n'est pas français on peut dire qu'il
y a en France une population étrangère
de l'ordre de 2
millions
d'habitants la population active est
environ de
1200000 non compris les Algériens non
compris les Algériens qui actuellement
ne figure pas parmi les étrangers mais
figure parmi les populations qui peuvent
librement venir sur le territoire
national les Algériens sont 800000 c'est
dire qu'avec quelques dizaines de
milliers d'Africains ce sont près de 3
millions d'étrangers qui amènent en
France un peu de leur
[Musique]
pays parmi ces 3 millions de personnes
il y a ceux qui sont recrutés à
l'étranger et qui viennent chez nous sur
contrat il y a ceux à qui la France est
ouverte librement par les accords
d'viant ou les accords de coopération et
enfin il y a ceux qui franchissent
clandestinement nos frontières tous
viennent en tout cas renforcer notre
main
d'œuvre la France a besoin de main d'AV
étran chère du fait de son expansion
économique qu'elle connaît depuis un
certain nombre d'années et aussi du fait
ce sont c'est l'aspect qualitatif de la
question du fait que les Français ont
abandonné les travaux à caractère
salissant ou pénible qui sont souvent
aussi des travaux peu rémunérés
lorsqu'un ouvrier arrive d'Espagne ou du
Portugal chez vous ou du Maroc ou
d'ailleurs il n'a pas de formation
professionnelle il n'a jamais travaillé
dans l'industrie automobile pour la
plupart non pour la plupart ce sont des
ouvriers agricoles alors vous les formez
al nous les formons vous avez comme
nationalité nous avons si ma mémoire est
fidèle 35 ou 36 nationalités en principe
il reste 2 ans
18inors ilé
proi il sagit là d'ouvri immigr
légalement et m d'un contrat de travail
le assurant salaire allocation et logie
décent
vous gagnez bien votre
vie bien
0000 FR pour
Mo vous arrivez envoyer de l'argent en
Espagne
combien peu
pr il gag ici en 3 gag une journée au
portug je suis venu i pour
étudier de savoir le travail et tout ça
c'est ça c'est pour cela que je suis
venu en France c'est pas question de
l'argent que je suis venu en
France mais dans les bidonvilles qui
cernent les grandes cités ouvrières
échouent ceux de nos anciennes colonies
qui viennent à l'aventure sans être
certain de trouver un emploi mais pour
lesquels l'entrée de notre pays n'est
que succintement contrôlée on vit comme
comme des chiens il y a pas d'eau pas
d'eau rien du tout
on cherche de l'eau de dehors de la
route
là l'électricité non plus non plus vous
avez du travail au moins si dans ce
momentl je
travaille mieux que l'année dernière non
cette année il le plus mauvais de toute
l'année comment ça se fait l'habitude il
y en a du travail dans ce momentl il y a
rien du tout j'ai rencontré autour de
Paris dans la région parisienne un
certain nombre de chômeurs pourquoi en
principe la mainœuvre étrangère ne
devrait pas être en chômage car elle
n'est elle ne vient en France elle n'est
introduite ou autorisée à travailler en
France que en fonction de nos besoins
pour occuper des emplois vacants c'est
des emplois bien déterminés pour cette
catégorie d'immigrants les clandestins
la vie commence en France par la
[Musique]
colère oui par la colère pas contre la
France mais contre la vie clandestine et
en conséquence misérable qu'ils doivent
mener jusqu'à la régularisation de leur
situation c'est plus une vie de rester
là vous savez qu'est-ce que vous le
reprochez exactement oh ben le bruit et
tout et puis la saleté alors vous pouvez
sortir nimporte quand ils sont là en
train de faire uriner on a vous leur
dire Madame tuas qu'à pas regarder ben
écoutez si vous sortez de chez vous et
puis que vous voyez le tableau alors
c'est c'est quand même pas tellement
joli je suis je suis marocain
que dire d'autres de ces 3 millions de
travailleurs étrangers dont nous venons
d'éfleurer les
problèmes peut-être et nous l'avons vu
que ceux qui sont sûrs de leur travail
et de leur logement n'ont pratiquement
pas de difficulté d'adaptation et ne
vivent pas en marche de la
société peut-être aussi que pour ceux
qui bénéficient de la libre circulation
entre leur pays et le nôtre il y a
danger de
et qu'il devrait pour eux comme pour
nous venir avec toute garantie d'emploi
et de
logement com alors peut-être
disparaîtrai les binonville et
l'animosité qui les entoure comme ils
ont disparu pour cet ouvrier espagnol
quel est votre niveau de vie disons vous
avez un appartement une voiture j'ai une
voiture j'ai un
appartement j'ai une je suis content je
travaille je suis
[Musique]
heureux